oh you know what this is for pride month how is it
okay cool yeah is it pride month no okay I don't
know what's wrong with this dude all right that
always comes up we'll put this up in June that's
why we're in purple there you go we've Justified
it but then Target got in trouble you might get
in trouble well I'm better than Target take
it away Roxy citizens of the reject Nation it
is time is that how you pronounce it I don't
know we're watching an awesome Finnish movie
today at least we hear it's great it's an action
movie that we know literally nothing about Greg
says he hears good things I've never even heard
of the film at all I heard they kill Nazis and
I said Jew girl we're watching this together
I walked up today and you said super Juice I
love a Nazi killing movie if you think that
I just did the best intro of all time leave
a like throughout this entire thing just hit
that like button comment button hit the like
button you're carrying it yeah she's doing really
well and if you want to see the entire thing if
you want to watch the full length of it all go
over and be a super sexy reject over on patreon
yes Greg she did all the things to hit all the
points Roxy Super Jew can do an intro it's true
[Music]
YouTube I need to tell you everything in this
movie fake so you know it's not okay that's
the finished word that cannot be translated
white-knuckled form of courage and unimaginable
determination oh do we have Susu Manifesto when
all hope is lost oh nice now we got still got
some hope oh okay 44 a heart of Nazis Warren's
in 45 so we got some time the second world war
is coming to an end this is an English Finland and
the Soviet Union have signed the Moscow Armistice
which decrees that Finland must disarm the Nazis
and drive them out of Lapland yes I'm following
the Nazis destroyed all roads Bridges and towns
deep in the wilderness of Lapland there is a
man who has decided to leave the war behind
him okay but was he a Nazi I don't think so
this is exciting I haven't even seen the trailer
for this I have like no idea what's gonna happen
what is he searching for do you think like I'm not
I don't have words today I know what he's doing
gold curdles I think that's what they are
because we just saw it yeah but
that's what they did back then
it's old oh man it's like a pulpy film
with a dog or a sheep a dog
100 positive is a dog
sheep's making weird noises back there [Laughter]
do you know much about planes like if I said are
those b-17s would you be able to identify yes
yes I would
damn what a great shot he
doesn't even look up yeah
because that's how frequently that's happening
man this has such good atmosphere I don't know
much about finland's part in World War II or
the way that they've set this up then what
good are you in this video Roxy it was just
interesting like you know you hear of the big
ones yeah uh the war took his wife Fury Rising
that is so much gold
oh that's a gold mine right there man jackpot baby
imagine how you would feel In This Moment you'd
forget that you had a dead wife this whole time
remember how excited he was with the one pellet
he's got hope but then they said when your hope
is lost sisu yeah and the Nazis don't give a
[__] about his hope oh look at it I'm ready
to protect my gold just because you've left the
war behind doesn't mean the war has left you nice
I love how there's been no
dialogue this entire time
whoa homeboy was cut up maybe they took
one of his organs oh yeah good call
as a haunting image right there you think they
found it and they're like we gotta shoot that
maybe chapter two the Nazis
I love the old school Western War
Vibe this is going for yeah but
that pulpy zest you don't see a lot
of Western World War II style things
it's true yeah rocking my brain for them
way more World War One Western stuff
oh damn it has all that gold on him
right now you know they're taking it
what a really long Dreadful passing
[__] he's riding to his death
anyway what does that mean
build up of Horrors here literally
entering Death Valley where do you
think he is trying to go to sell the
gold that's my best guess too yeah
I feel like they're gonna kill this dog
because they think it's a sheep yeah it's a
sheep killer where you think you're going old man
there's nothing down there be made sure of that
what do you got there oh no this stuff is
a gold miner oh man take a look at this
I'm a rich boy
what the [__] of gold get
down on your knees Grandpa
oh my God
we got gold thank you Wowie
talk about a breaking an actor holy [__]
nicely done man
those other Nazis are about to
show up ugh damn way to go Gramps
oh my God that's what I'm talking about Roxanne
it's just we know what the next thing is so I'm
not I can't celebrate yet you know they're
on their way back I know it's going to be 50
minutes ago I can't wait I feel like he's gonna
walk out alive well otherwise the movie would be
over no I mean by the end of the movie I think
it's just gonna be him killing a bunch of Nazis
they're gonna go find him where's the dog
what happened was golden it was on the horse
you're gonna tell him about the gold
uh he had a piece on him
he knows
wow
please don't shoot the horse I
think they're going too please don't
I think they did shoot him maybe
oh oh that is not cool man [Music] that's
good he's walking to his death means
ah gross who really don't like animal deaths
they're coming for the gold this might be
insensitive but he has to get up and hide the gold
in his like butt and his CH like he needs to like
keep some of the gold on him yeah it's obviously
not what he's thinking about but you're about
to lose all of it how is he gonna make it out of
this alive he loves his that's his pet though too
oh [__] his Gold's all scattered yeah
uh that's where the sea suit quality
comes and I hope we're saying that right
I think I said sissue you might be right we
could have looked it up on Google beforehand
what are you gonna do with that no
smart man not really he's hiding
in the shadows in the Smoke
hell yeah
where is he gonna go and I take it back you're
right I don't mean not really it's just like was
oh all right two totally different
experiences you're like so wrapped up for the
turmoil of the situation and I'm like oh this
is gonna be some cool action we're gonna get it
huh
this is so impressive how they conducted this
with like no dialogue for so much of this is
not dialogue driven I love it it's like a
visual thrill I take everything back he is
so impressive this is like giving him enough time
to what is a mine what's not oh my God [Laughter]
so did he pick up a mine and throw it I guess
he picked up a mine and threw it you and you
on the sides of the road now I shouldn't you guys
be looking down are you idiots Nazis [Applause]
look down
pick two of our female friends and bring
them to me oh that's cruel and some roll
oh he's not gonna let he's gonna give
up his gold for them he's not gonna let
them die right I mean because his wife
you yeah all right look how effective
of a shot this is I know this is there's
some just amazing shots in this Big Mate
they must be so buried that you can't even
yeah see it why are they tied together
how many chapters do you think there are seems to
be one every 10 minutes I would say nine chapters
eight chapters eight chapters he has given
us orders and head to Norway from Finland
immediately did you tell him he just killed seven
of our men I did he thinks we were lucky why
of his number they know who
he is now it is like a John
Wick situation yeah he was a Finnish
Commando the most feared in his unit
the boogeyman he fought in the winter War lost
his home and his family to the Russians ah okay
but it looks like he has over 300 Russian kills so
he's most ruthless when he is in this position is
this based on a true story I highly doubt it they
gave him a name they call him koshai the immortal
we are not turning back we are losing the war in
a few months this all will be over for us when
we get back they will hang us all he's desperate
to that cold is our way out desperate because of
what he's done no [__] they're gonna hang you
it's smart to set it at this specific time that
way it justifies the villain's motive I just like
the writing of the choice of that like yeah okay
it's more than just I want gold yeah yeah this is
a chance for him to survive too yeah and it can't
be because you care about your men and Vengeance
it's like we wouldn't believe that yeah you only
care about yourself I bet that there is Merit to
some of this the legend of this guy I don't know
but there was gold miners at the time Russia
and sort of the most some of the most ruthless
punch it or throw some dirt on it
is it stuffing it damn was that dirt I think so
what do they say you're supposed to do gunpowder
right oh hey it might be right is this dog still
alive I I think his dog ran off but definitely oh
yeah yeah the dog lives I love this sheep
how fast the Sheep is going it looks like
a soft coat of Wheaten Terrier couldn't tell it
was a dog now you have a very specific breed in
mind it's a little wider than soft go to
wheat Interiors there are sheep breeders
they're gonna see him right now right
I would love it if this guy
does not talk the entire movie
nicely done
oh boy what is his game plan
here I mean it's working for now
oh to make them run out of gas I know
oh no so that he masks his smell I
think he's gonna blow it up Oh no you're
probably right oh no oh [__] oh [__]
release the dog no how many
animal deaths are gonna be
the [__] is he doing he's
covered in gasoline I guess
see you just set yourself on fire
what a crazy strategy he's holding
on to the gold to keep himself down
what's his plan to outlast them
what a shot that's gorgeous
he should be a little mermaid
hot cake oh no get midi gold
he's gonna kill him
I love this guy this is unbelievable
this movie come out this year yeah
set his head back up oh he's
breathing the air oh yeah
the oxygen from what I don't know oh my sure
there's a thing to explain it into the comments
I don't know I'm rolling with it I mean I guess
we all have oxygen in our whoa that was insane
there's oxygen in our blood
I don't know I think in his throat like his
lungs oh yeah that makes more sense the pipes
I don't I don't know you don't know how it works
guys I don't know with Biology in your air pipes
this effect of seeing the blood
in the water is unbelievable
it's like oh I just love how terrified they
are he's under water he's gonna pull down the
cut the string it's so fun spooky that dude
didn't like German at all he's gonna flip
it and then he's gonna be use the boat
as a shield and breathe air as the boat
is upside down like Captain Jack Sparrow
yep one more meter and I'll have you shots
this version is punishable by Death
just gave her a man an opening yeah why would
what
desertion is punishable by Death yeah yeah
stream kinetic visuals
no
hey oh [__] what are they gonna do use them
find me a boat why because of scorched Earth Greg
obviously it's like the best action characters
your protagonist is the smartest person in the
room and he's so so is the smartest person
in this room in the universe he could have
defeated World War II for us but that's why you
and I don't know what he's gonna do yeah and I
like how you have to just watch him do it yeah
you have to like play along and go what is he
about doing he's gonna use the bonus The Shield
of that thing it was like wrong every time rocks
yeah holy [__] this is Hometown is I
think this is supposed to be the town
where he was going to it's like what is
gold good for when you have nothing left
he hasn't spoken a word this
whole time huh no well we got
a couple grunts I can't believe
they have his dog sheep thank you
is this flashback or is
this yeah I think it's PTSD
oh that's neat
just in such Adoration of the uh
stylish flourishes that this movie
does because like they just warp his
actual surroundings and throw in some
sound design instead of like cutting to
footage it's really clever this script
for this must have looked so strange
must be written and directed by the
same person must be no way did a director
take this script and make this this genius
whole Vision oh no he's being baited oh what
did he they ask him for oh no dynamite oh
they're gonna hang him and he's gonna live he's
gonna find a way to get down
his neck will just Snap It Off
how will he get out of this
because he's got that thing on
his back but his hands are tight yeah but it's him
he leaves him a piece for your troubles hmm seem
masterfully faking his own death yeah okay now
oh my God oh my God is he
really gonna do that oh oh
you know this is worries I'm sorry
he's got to get the dog to climb up
him and chew off the Rope yeah or
nament I'm having a hard time
speaking right now I know
you're perturbed at the moment oh good
good oh that's a benefit oh my God out
of all the gore stuff that that is
the one that's bothering me the most
oh no I thought it was a finish plane [Applause]
oh he's gonna totally hijack that plane
legs around them
they're probably so confused
where the dog came from
this son of a [__] is still alive
and shoot the dog too oh hell no
oh
he had it easy
oh man don't give up you need to feed your dog too
what's the realization that this guy knows
where the other guys are that he can maybe
take the uniform and go in a plane yeah keep your
eye on the prize man go keep your eye on the prize
God
these wounds it's like I
[__] about a paper cut oh
some really good makeup
he's just so brutal oh my God this guy
walked again it's the worst thing I've
seen in this war the plane is ready
what about the rest of our Squad we
don't need us to get to Norway the
boys have a crate full of booze and
a truck full of [__] I'm sure they'll
figure something out they're like rappers
I feel like that woman's gonna murder some people
yeah she should and then she
should marry suzu instantly
what is CeCe's name oh I haven't even asked
myself that question this whole movie yeah
this is the plan this is something else I've been
so back and forth with is this movie dubbed or
not but then I like look at their mouths and
they're speaking English speaking English yeah
the pilot has been hanged that's my
rope what that's the Rope I used to
hang coffee with how do you know that
well we'll give that to them he's back
what's so funny do you [__] really think you
have succeeded they'll just keep coming back
do you really believe that he's Immortal
no he just refuses to die cool I love her
this is not about who's the
strongest this is about not
giving up and he won't worry so
funny is that you your boyfriend
and everything that is left of your
sorry ass company are already dead
I was just working on getting
him his gold back what oh wow
thank you
marry me if they've gotta
fall in love I understand
that's not the purpose but this is my purpose Greg
oh give her her power
wow that's a lot of guns yeah
six chapters we were close
no I think there's gonna be
an aftermath yeah it's gonna be
seven chapters then yeah yeah
I'm back
whoa awesome
God I love this music
give the middle finger
oh damn
oh my God
what's up they're all dead
we are almost there step on it that was the best
you gotta know to give up give up the goldfish
that wasn't a bad strategy on the Nazism
he got up there fast but it was pointless
of course this guy could put up a fight
oh is the other guy up there now dude no it's
just him I think I saw a stunt double at one point
you're such a dumbass that's when you've
shoot him he's singing more gold for me
I hope it's the lemon that's him oh let's go shy
they totally have the upper hand
on it they just don't take it
he leaves him to live now the
woman are gonna come though
yeah yeah The Suicide Squad
better run [__] [Laughter]
that guy was so good we just had to make sure
he was really unlikable before he dies why did
he just shoot that guy more gold for them
yeah but did the other guy even know about
the gold of course he's been saying we need
the gold who's still that's everyone no the
other guy yeah but he's the three of them have
been in the same proximity the whole time oh
that guy he probably would have at some point
get on the plane
wow he's really on this plane he
hooked it and he's climbing you see him
still down there he's not
God the strength
it's actually kind of a terrifying
shot it's ridiculous as it is it's
pretty scary that's some Tom Cruise stuff
that's why he didn't kill him he needs a pilot ah
it's like a more believable
Fast and Furious scenario
we might have a problem oh my God
foreign
kill him
ouch
has always happened with the finale
bad guys come on kick his ass
why isn't he why
thank you oh my God
that's the most I've ever seen an action hero
get messed up in a first movie
unless this is just a one-off
[Music]
whoa it looks like they
really blew something up there
[Laughter] [Music] I even forgot what
the myth name they gave him is like
oh that is also dead something
like Invincible all right
forget about Wikipedia oh he's gotta jump out
of the plane where's your gold he's carrying
it okay nope I'm wrong he's looking for it
right now Roxy you idiot he's caring come on
after all this he's not going to
get his gold oh he's strapping in
[Applause]
I mean sure why not maybe he was looking
for a parachute not for his gold oh yeah
you're right a little bit of exposition
Finland would go a long way sometimes he
can't speak he can't give us any Exposition
for my American Noggin I can't keep up with
your visual storytelling the fact that this
man is gonna walk out of this is unbelievable
a foreign language this must
be the Finnish people right
that's cool
must be do you think it's the last one [Laughter]
face sweet digs man
I hope he has a crazy American accent I
don't know if we're gonna hear him I hope
we don't but if we do I hope it's American
what consulate is this where are we I don't
know other places outside of California I
think it's London the last letters were nkki
I'd like to cash this gold please
[Applause] it's awesome
heaters
[Laughter]
we already dressed by the same guy here
or a fascinating pulp film I
think it was a Finnish Bank
it seems that way well [__] Roxy's stryer
I always said Roxanne Roxanne Roxanne Roxanne
Roxanne I did hours and hours of research before
doing our review right now and we have discovered
that sisu is inspired by a real life figure um you
know how to pronounce his name oh man you might
just nailed that I don't know oh no go back what
happened anyway it's a Finnish person with the
nickname being the white death believed to have
killed over 500 enemy soldiers during the winter
war and he's inspired by Rambo from First Blood I
could totally see those Inspirations so yeah that
was crazy though no I like how it plays into like
the whole legendary aspect of it all uh that was
a really fun beautiful creative film how'd you
feel how does it feel can you enjoy a good pulpy
War action movie or do you go like ah this is
is having fun with something that's a little too
real I thought that movie was amazing oh yeah I
think it's a totally fair question especially like
um you know most World War II movies are
um Holocaust movies or like very Jewish
focused as which makes sense um and I have a lot
I have a hard time watching a lot of them because
um I lost family in in the Holocaust and also
just as my connection of being Jewish and so
it's interesting a lot of times when you think
about the war you don't think about all of the
implications and effects of all different country
I mean it's there's a reason it's called World
War II right but you know it's a it's a whole
[__] world war and um I when we started it I
was like wow I don't know anything about finished
representation in the war like what happened to
their people or what they were and you see
how greatly affected obviously this isn't
a documentary but like the the communities are
affected people's families are killed everything
is like burnt to a crisp and on both sides they're
thinking about like how do you live after this
like trying to figure out how to have life after
this so because of that I didn't feel like like
when you're asking do I have a hard time watching
something that is more pulpy or action-packed like
this it didn't feel disrespectful to the war like
I do have a hard time with movies that it feels
like that they're making light of it I didn't feel
like this made light of the situation at all it
just showed a different side of it and also uh in
this for a similar reason that I love and glorious
bastards it's like you want to see the Nazis get
theirs like you want you want to see their asses
handed to them and this movie does that you
know like you you just want to see you want to
see there they get their um yeah how do you spell
it come Muppets I don't know how to spell it I've
never tried there's no r in it yeah there might
be now I don't know I don't know I often had me
question things that I shouldn't question you know
what I mean though where it's like this wasn't
like oh what the f that's rude it was like yeah
get them and a different side of things and just
yeah I really really enjoyed this movie I love
that I didn't know any of the actors I love that
I didn't know anybody working on it it felt like
you were able to just get fully sucked into this
world I think multiple times throughout it we were
taken away just in awe of the way it looked and
the way it sounded like they just did an excellent
job with this yeah I felt like it was a transport
of experience I really felt like I was planted
there it was a really great like mood it was a
mood piece as well and that's a really good point
that you made actually about how it doesn't feel
disrespectful to it like they don't take the piss
out of the knots about what the kind of Horrors
they dealt them like the kind of fear that they
did impose as well I really did I think that's
because they did lead into like the dread and
the horror prior to like cool action to kind of
show you like no and then you have the the female
prisoners as well uh being you know dragged along
here showing like no they a lot of cruel acts that
are reminding you of it versus yeah undercutting
it in any way you know and to build up this like
Mythos around this guy who uh because the Nazis
were even though they were at this time where
they were losing or like on the verge of losing
they build up the Mythos of this this Legend Who
has been able to like kill so many people and
I forgot where I was going with that I was going
Roxy you're very smart you're saying yeah because
you're a genius so glad that you're on this
channel and I was saying Greg thanks so much for
seeing my value and my worth uh yes that is that
was part of where I was going to before something
I told Roxy you're leading this because I am very
lethargic today you said you were getting lost in
the movie like you you were able to really fully
get lost in it which I think there's something to
your point that I was actually saying about um you
said that it wasn't disrespectful to it which I
was talking about I guess they know how to do this
as great blend of like hiding fantasy mixed with
not under underscoring the reality Horrors just
I was trying to say a fancier version of what you
said and I should just get this I think that you
nailed it you crushed it um I another movie that
I love is JoJo rabbit did you ever see that yeah
I thought it was so so great and they did such
a great job and it does show that like you can
really tackle any topic as long as you kind of
have a point of view on it and you want to and you
are being respectful of that topic and it's like I
I feel like for this they gave us exactly what we
wanted which was you're right they the stakes are
not are the Nazis going to win or lose like we
know this isn't this is in Fall of 44 they know
that they're on their way out they're desperate
and that almost makes the movie more enjoyable
because usually you're dealing with Nazis in the
height of their power and they've got like they're
swinging their big dicks but they think that you
know whatever that expression is swinging their
people anyway swords is it swinging there whatever
you know I'm talking about but you don't know
okay I think you were trying to say
Greg I'm so happy to be on this channel
after everything you've done here
but usually we're dealing with these these Nazis
that like they think that they're about to [__]
pulverize and here we're dealing with desperate
Nazis and that's like yeah kind of more a more
fun place to watch because you're like all right
this guy is this guy is not only about to kick
him when they're down as they [__] should be but
he's about to give these women the power to do it
back to them what's been done to them a thousand
times um and even like the little implications
of with the gun like opening her legs I mean you
know that these women are being [__] tortured
by the these guys uh and they're making them walk
through the Minefield yeah like they don't look at
them as people um and so completely dehumanized so
to to see this and see every single Nazi in this
movie Die not one of them lives it was like you
know they introduced like 40 Nazis and we killed
every one of them yeah we killed them at the gas
station we killed them in the plane we killed them
and the tanks in the tanks we killed them like
literally every stop you know there was no no Nazi
Left Alive yeah um so that was like yeah every
one of you guys who's gonna come up against this
man and I also like that like we got a little bit
of his backstory but we didn't need like how you
feeling the blank yeah you fill in the blanks he's
wearing his wedding ring the girl in the truck
talks tank talks about the legend of him that he
lost everything you get it like they showed it
enough we didn't need some monologue like the
year was 1940 and you know we got yeah yeah a
lot you have to keep it mysterious if you know
him too well that it actually would make it less
believable because this has to be a fantasy of
what we're watching take place who was this guy's
now I don't know I'm never committed to memory
oh you think it's a soft I imagine it's a soft
horma why do you imagine that because most names
like that usually have a soft J right Am I Wrong
um I think if they're uh Middle Eastern
or if they're um Hispanic but Jay like
let's put it to the test let's see Roxy I
would say this is probably drama Dorma tomorrow
[Music] because like you know within the other way
like whatever and then the Jose or like like an H
oh wait they do call him corpy in the movie so
yeah they do actually cite his name oh that's what
that was I kept wondering if they actually said
his real name there the whole time well I think
this guy was a phenomenal performance because he
carries this movie without saying any dialogue
till the very end and you you gotta communicate
so much just through your body language and your
expression and what I love too is even though he
is one of those this is this is a hard thing you
gotta capture with an action movie like this
this is where like the Fast and Furious movies
have been failing for a lot of people is there's
no I haven't seen the latest one so I can't attest
to that one they've all succeeded for me so I am
not a good test audience I think there's no Stakes
anymore oh my God the stakes are so high because
the stakes are family okay well I think what is
a bigger stake than family you don't fear for
Dominic Toretto about to die you know you don't
feel for the danger they're in you don't know
that's true I don't I can't say that about the
latest Fast and Furious we only have two left
um oh I can't wait um well I think here when
a character is one where whenever he's in the
room it seems like he's gonna handle business
it's hard to still provide Stakes it's still
it's hard to make you still feel the sense
of danger that this guy is in and I thought the
movie actually did a really good job at getting
you to feel the suspense of that situation
without without its undercutting him either
that I think that's a really really impressive
line to write in an action totally because it's
gonna feature the whole time I fail himself
and stuff yeah theoretically it's a struggle
yeah theoretically he could have died in this
movie I didn't know that he was very beginning
of this movie right I didn't know that he wasn't
going to die at any point you know like as he's
getting this the living [__] kicked out
of him on the plane I'm thinking to myself
maybe he dies and and that's like one of the
things about this and then maybe like the plane
goes down and the gold is lost forever maybe he
dies maybe he makes it out but then he's going
to die so he gives all the gold to the women maybe
you know like in my head I'm going through all the
options and I didn't feel 100 positive this man
was gonna make it out into the bank but it also
felt not realistic as in like this movie is so
realistic but it didn't feel like that's egregious
because they set up this Legend around him and
I feel like they set these rules in this world
and then they played by the roles that they set
as long as it's believable within the world that
takes place in you're fine right but it's like he
lived through a plane crash and I'm not sitting
here like oh come on because it like yeah we saw
him strapping I was like yo homie's a fighter we
saw him we saw him in the water taking out all the
people bleeding up we like that was crazy we saw
him use another man's neck for oxygen yeah I want
to look at the logistics of that that'd be fun
it's a good Chase movie man do you really want
to look it up I'll do it later do it right now
okay I want to do it right now all right I was
like I feel like I was changing the subject I'm
like I feel like she really wants to look this
up actually you're all right that is a good Chase
movie and the people probably want to talk more
about that but what I need to know is can you
and breathe through it well because you know
how they like tricky people to get them oxygen
to their lungs yeah yeah that's that with the pen
all right okay here here there's it's on Reddit
okay never seen someone suck oxygen from a slit
throat before laugh my ass
off uh original ideas yeah
can we stick to the topic okay okay doesn't
oxygen turn into carbon dioxide in the lungs
after inhaling it so he wouldn't have been taking
an actual oxygen rather carbon dioxide no but it's
before it goes to the lungs right yeah this
person's answering yeah air is 21 oxygen wall
the air you exhale is 16 to 18 oxygen your body is
built with a lot of Reserve to handle sub-optimal
conditions so it only requires a fraction of the
oxygen in the environment there's also a fair
bit of dead space in your mouth oh yeah in there
wow windpipes et cetera where no oxygen is used
one of the reasons mouth to mouth resuscitation
can work oh now whether or not someone can gulp
enough air bubbles like Sonic and not get a lot
of water with it is a different question uh-huh
and I'm more aware this guy's at you're thinking
about this movie too hard I think you're right
though yeah I thought that part was sick that was
awesome I think this movie is gonna definitely
gain a big following I hope so and also it's a
Chase movie did you know that it's a good chance
they did a good job too I love Keanu Reeves and
John Wick but [__] me sisu is nasty breathing
from a Dead Nazi throat [__] yeah that's how
I feel that's it yeah that's exactly how I feel
well guys or would you rate it out of 10.
well because of the Chase movie aspect of it
I feel like that's like an 8.5 nice
what brings that what's the 1.5
that is not bring you to a 10. um I think that
um like the you're saying why isn't it perfect
for me yeah sure because I don't think this move
I think this was the best version of this movie
that they could do but a 10 movie for me like I
know that this isn't a 10 movie in general but for
me has like love um which this lacked in certain
ways you know like a uh I I like like familial
relationships like parental relationships love
interests um siblings things that connection and
this movie lacks um connection with another human
what's uh what was the latest Fast and Furious
rating for you it's perfect it said it's got all
those things siblings yeah no no no I mean
is this a better movie than that movie Yes
do I love the fast franchise yes but like
if we're gonna do this style movie this is
as good as it gets you know what is it for you
I'll give you like a 9 out of ten why not a ten
um doesn't have like the brother Dynamics
it's the same as me like doesn't have the
family uh oh you're making fun of me no
I I got the oh so you're making fun of me
I think uh I'm not I'm not in I'm not entirely
sure what it was um it's like I was very much
invested I would say I was emotional I definitely
was emotionally invested uh as much as I did like
get pulled into as much I was saying like I
still get pulled into the stakes and the danger
I would also weirdly say I didn't really get
pulled into the fear of the situation and I could
have used a little bit of that I suppose would be
a knit picky be nitpicky man if you've got enough
nitpicks because yeah I think that was one of the
things that I I was like such adoration not very
good uh I was in such Adoration of that of them
why did you say what's that I must say it's a net
uh but there's also the like so much here that
I'm that I love about it and there's like this
one little percentage in my heart that I'm like
not quite clicking with even though I feel like
most of my heart does and yeah I could have used a
little bit more of a I don't know if I could have
used it I think there was a bit of an emotional
substance that I could have lashed latched onto
more than just the immediate situation but then
again the immediate situation is a big part what
makes it brilliant this is like a Fury Road meets
Rambo you know yeah they did make it more like
um theatrical like it's more not a popcorn flick
but it is more like intense and less heartfelt
yeah at times uh what that heartfelt is the thing
they would go for no no that's what I'm saying
this is the best version of this movie you can
do exactly which is great um did you pick up on
the fact that this was a really good solid Chase
movie I did about like 20 minutes into it I was
thinking oh that's interesting they've been on
the same road the whole time and I can't wait to
break that down with Roxy would you call it a road
trip film yes it's a buddy road trip in a way it's
what's this guy's name what is his name scorpion
the Nazis that's what they should have called it
and I love that they have that at the
beginning and I like that term and I
feel like we should use that and
I wish we had a translation for it
why can't we just say Caesar we can I'm just
saying like they they said that they can't
translate so now in normal day life I can't say
CCU and how people know what I'm talking about
well that's how you help normalize that kind of
terminology so you help normalize The Finnish
language in the streets of Los Angeles so
can you give me any other word in Finnish hmm
[Music]
or this is 95 on Rotten Tomatoes
bummer that hello is just High hey it's hey hi hey
that kimin that came I don't know
what those dots above the a mean ah
all right yes but it means
how do you think they used to sound and then
everyone's bored Rock and
I think thank you is ketos
well well ketos to you guys at home oh nicely
done what that's how you transition close us
out Roxy all right you're gonna want to
do a couple different things before you
leave us Number One You're Gonna Want
to like if you haven't already which
why haven't you done it you're going to want
to leave a comment because I read them all
no say something um uh and and tixie and
tixie say something nice please antiquesy
means excuse me I guess in Finnish um and then
also if you're not already a patron you're going
to want to be one for the next video because
it's the best way to see more of us in our
entire reactions and you might have missed
it if you're just here on YouTube and then
um you're going to want to follow the real rejects
which is just real rejects on social and is that
right yeah I thought we were you said two things
no it's a few things okay all right and then
um you're going to want to tell Greg how happy
you are with me and then um you're gonna want to
fool you follow me one more did you say Follow You
Then You're Gonna Wanna follow me at Roxy Strayer
uh check me out on the world girls and then
thank you so much uh we appreciate you coming
forget anything Greg okay
goodbye or more like not come in
okay look at how you say it knock
knock him in I'll look it up [Music]